[Music]
what is up everybody good morning and
welcome back to keen spot live purge
here David's bad show guys and today we
are playing destiny to the best game
ever there's my favorite game yeah
shadow keep it is out it's poppin' and
we're gonna check it out a little bit
you guys probably have seen all the
beginning things so we're kind of
jumping into it a little bit more mid
campaigning yes so for those of you who
are in a destiny who have bought it
we've tried to play it yesterday you
might have had some trouble because
servers were down
I mean well there was a lot of games
yesterday right there was a 2003 which
had some server issues as well for a
little bit not as bad as destiny I was
like Ghost Recon which I think was fine
but with their servers but des CT was
down for like almost a majority of the
day at some point they literally just
took off all servers for emergency
maintenance hey they got it done though
yeah they did get it done but you know a
lot of people were kind of a upset
naturally but yeah so there's still
people there's still streamers who have
already reached the endgame the post 900
pound of life they've reached that hard
cap of armour and then you've got we
just didn't want to repeat the early
intro mission so you're just going to
kind of see the mid game different areas
of the Moon see what's up with Eris morn
check out some finisher moves check out
some super some alien bodies flying all
over the place it's gonna be a great
time we're gonna have we're gonna have a
lot of fun with this yeah
and our camera was covering it but was
your score 804 is that your current
score or I don't want to talk about this
I was I was in meetings yesterday I was
I was doing things I was working but yes
yeah my current light level is
is that 804 when this loads right here
you're going to notice some blues
because right now we're in that soft cap
area where blue armor is dropping at a
higher at a higher level but it should
be going up actually like right now like
there's stuff and the postmaster that
probably just actually dropped higher
than what I currently had it at already
going up they're already going up man
look at this this is called efficiency
this is this is how I roll in destiny we
login we level up that's desirable you
see you see the shirt this is a warlock
that means we got big brains man we this
is how we we played this game I love
that you came prepared
yeah well you know you'll notice see
there's something new and destiny here
where they're really going this RPG
rally notice all those numbers now on
that armor the mobility resilience
recovery this wasn't here two days ago
you know they used to be different mods
and stuff and now it's like they really
want you to kind of tweak things and do
stuff and you got these different like
new mod systems and definitely um for
those of you might be confused with the
system stay tuned the game spot because
we were working on guides and breakdowns
that really kind of dig deep into this
stuff and get into that nitty-gritty but
check out we got the digital deluxe
edition and so that came with a lot of
cool pre-order stuff like this it's an
exotic ghost shell it's a nice little
green glowy thing you guys can check
that out and I can attach any of my like
earlier projections to it be like all
you want even a little owl there Oh
feeling a little artsy you an aspiring
lawyer whatever whatever floats you go
you know um and the cool thing is is
that your character now who's floating
you see the ghost with them and you also
see the sparrow in the background that
was something good so we've got this is
a actually an ever verse one that I was
able to get to check that out cool
we're gonna be we're gonna be riding out
on that and doing that doing flips and
things like that off the jumps yeah guys
feel free to ask all the questions you
want David here I've been waiting for
this day a couple years or two years now
so
ask away I saw someone in chat actually
talk about the they were talking about
the finishers this is something totally
new now every class has a finisher that
they do like so where when you week when
the opponent grows weak enough you
basically get to just do a little finish
move now that's the default but you can
get premium ones to which I have them
unlocked so you've got this savage
haymaker you just oh right in the dome
man just get them right there you got
this drop kick it's pretty fun and then
my favorite that I have a quip which
we'll see out in the wild is gonna be
this tornado game implemented fighting
games into exactly so let me just grab
some quick bounties and then we will fly
to the moon mandible claw side be
thankful you weren't playing yesterday
queues up the wazoo
no for sure but that's good news so that
means so many people were trying to play
right that it was difficult in a way
good news like it sucks yeah but people
playing that's like it's it's a you know
destiny has created a new environment
for new players like they are all ready
for this stuff
Chris perhaps is worst at I have taken
th spot as the new destiny person he has
made he has been replaced he's now doing
he's still he's still drying and leader
shooter at heart and he's still
following along and kind of nudging the
video team in the right direction with
how to cover destiny at the moment but
he is I am here now so you're gonna see
my lovely face with destiny more often
in the future I hope all right so let's
get to
the moon the black shirt environments
[Music]
here we go
but uh so for those who play destiny one
you're gonna recognize a lot of this
section of the moon but there's gonna be
some caveats and there's gonna be a lot
of differences compared to what you
might know because it's not just a
remaster it really does feel remade like
almost from the ground up new textures
and everything and like there's this
level of Polish and pockmarks that have
been engraved within the moon that
haven't been seen before and it's really
cool so I I'm loving it
yeah that's awesome they can kind of
revamp a game and make it sure for sure
wow this is a rechargeable battery pack
so I'm I'm good for this so 0hx brought
up a good point it's only free until
warmind kind of that's that's a half and
a half we actually have a really
in-depth video that yours truly made and
and it's your destiny to which version
is right for you and if you do the
free-to-play version you actually get a
lot more than just the base campaign and
war mine you get access to forsaking
destinations you get access to shadow
cube destinations and you get access to
a lot of Annual Pass environments things
like the reckoning things like black
armory forges it's it's a good time for
sure I think for the free-to-play
section people are getting a lot of bang
for their buck fight continues this is
our favorite uh you know emo darkness
former guardian Eris morn she's here eat
it's just being leaked by something
now that's nightmare I see those old
nightmares hovering around
I didn't notice at first but now I do
and it's kind of all over the place
they're like Iron Man they they haunt
her you know that's what they do
so we're gonna have fun playing on xbox
because although I am okay with the
controller I'm used to the the 60 to 120
frame frame rate on PC so we'll see
so spikey yeah yeah you like run into
somebody I can give one marks be like
hey we're gonna go that way that we're
gonna go that way
is your proper turn signals and epic
entrance to the abyss yeah which is not
what I want 360 noscope no I'm not gonna
be able to do at 360 noscope
oh yeah that's no bueno let's uh let's
get this exotic alan gamer guys says
destiny three possible to be made not
anytime soon not for at least five years
I mean they I mean look at this massive
update adjusted dude so patrols are now
given by these nightmares that basically
like dead figments it used to be actual
little beacons on the ground and you
would have to stop but now it's these
guys and you're like there are too many
of them everything makes you wanna bet
yeah he's like you'll never get this
done as I good buddy I've been doing
this for I've got I got our arch line
343 with me here and Johnny Johnny TM
trademark that seven three oh nine seven
three oh nine so I'm getting distracted
with chests and stuff the wool we'll
make our way to the
to the mission which should be right
there okay Daniel says so when I loaded
shadow keep yesterday all my previous
DLC is that I haven't completed yet I
couldn't access do you know why so all
the previous deals see that they haven't
completed yet they couldn't access that
doesn't make sense um it might just be
it it depends on what platform but it
might be that those DLC weren't properly
recognized like the entitlements or you
play it on a different platform than
what you did earlier with crossfade
because if you do cross eight you still
have to own the paid entitlements in
order to access them so if I have
forsaken on PC but I don't have it on
xbox but I bought shadow keep on xbox
I'm not gonna have forsaken on that that
makes sense so there's a there's still
some caveats that uh and there was some
weird glitches going on yesterday right
with those logging in and stuff so maybe
it's it's temporary yeah I think so find
out where this this missions
okay
[Music]
it's near a temple like the sound
effects sounds really good sound is
alright time to die
let me see if I can finish on the staff
I got some Johnny peopIe up so I think I
feel like Ben might have mentioned that
or just talking about Mortal Kombat do I
play Borderlands 3 um idea on
Borderlands 3 and I did some coverage
for it I did like a little evolution
video going across the graphics from
Borderlands 1 all the way onward but uh
hey as actually now our de facto border
lands 3 guy he's been doing a lot of
cool guides you should check out about
the coolest weapons like the wildest
wackiest legendary weapons you know
which there's a lot there's a there is
there's a lot so it should be should be
cool destiny - shadow frames
I love the Justice says by the way
what's up Persian David thanks for
showing this gameplay yeah you think
that's creepy anyone who's played a
vanilla destiny probably had a heart
attack when they saw this thing this
little area has been teased at getting
the heebie-jeebies yeah seanix that area
51
Brandon her Nana's we know we need all
the games while people on the charity
stream we're missing you will yeah Extra
Life is coming man it's right around the
corner
jean-luc is like the battery mind behind
it
some great stuff guys will it's a got a
little a little portal here
Daniel says I'm looking for a new co-op
game to play with my wife would you
choose destiny to shadow creep over
Borderlands 3 um yeah maybe only it will
I mean it Spence if you guys have like
pretty open humor and you can stand kind
of like on the nose so you might be a
good pic this is just it swag here but I
think destined to it's so much more
based around playing with friends and
having that kind of like community I
think you guys will have a great time
if you're playing it with a partner I
really do think that's a good way to
I'm shattered remember how to use a
cipher with the Patrol and that's pretty
good I know a missus on Bessie 2 is very
friendly Mike said I'd stop playing
destiny a little while ago to play other
games so how's it been seeing this game
play on the moon is super nostalgic and
is actually making me when it comes back
shadows
yeah do it it's free man that's like
it's free to play you're gonna get if
you haven't played destiny to or if you
dropped off and you're like a laughs
returning player I cannot think of a
better time than now
honestly everyone is like the whole
community is super excited to see this
like shot of adrenaline going Jesse you
know what I mean like we're seeing the
numbers of concurrent players on Steam
and it's like hey it's so nice to see
you whoa
it's like I know I know it seems kind of
stressful with the help farmers it's
like late for so long you're lucky you
know when you're gonna die I want you to
stay alive and it's just the shooter in
these is like red is bad that is bad the
time to kill and PVE is still so long
you know
yeah there's any power level so it's
like what up crime welcome back nice to
see you as always
yeah what's up you gotta go to the top
floor yeah yeah I love the music it's
like any sort of hive which is an enemy
race with any sort of hive moon like
music it's always like this in like
trance makes it like work just try it
I
harsh Onix says wait hold up this is
free I don't need a season pass what
about the black armor and stuff okay
great question um so black armory is
free and except for the raid okay so the
end game great stuff is still locked
behind the wall and certain exotics are
locked behind but the main activity of
black armor in particular which was the
forges that's right that's just kind of
included it's it's really interesting
how they they have it set up now
mama dbl fees are included on the new
light free version so the four you have
the Destiny vanilla then you've got
their service iris and war mine
these are year one and you get
everything included in them full stop
everything all the exotics the raids the
endgame stuff it's all there with the
annual pass stuff that let me do the
finisher yeah yeah come back with the
annual pass stuff it's a little more
pockmark there's caveats involved but so
much for yourself available
it's pretty awesome it's really awesome
all right let's uh we're gonna pop a
little seed baby and I hope taste
watching because I probably gonna miss a
lot of this well that's what's gonna go
see some of the mad
underestimated yourself I can do a
little air 200 it's like a palm to the
face and elbows and an elbow with the
kick it misses you guys having fun dude
I'm like I don't think I can stop
smiling today right now we're playing on
xbox but David usually plays on PC
correct so I'm still trying to get used
to this controller right now and this 30
frame rate your score transfer over what
do you mean my score like my like my
peers like wait how do you like know for
example this one all the way up so if
you establish your cost safe stuff you
can just transfer so I was literally
playing if you see like 30 minutes ago
and I was like let me yeah I'll say let
me go on stream i'm gonna take my xbox
and just my characters right there it's
really really convenient this crypto
cliff that you're seeing right now so I
got the collector's edition there's
actually a physical crypto clip with a
whole puzzle that came in and I opened
it up it took me forever but I got it
open and as soon as I opened it there's
a URL with the code and if you log in
and type in the code you get this random
like dark screen it's like an Arg thing
and it's like well he's like the weird
symbol start appearing and we found out
that other people in the community they
got different URLs and they all get
different codes and so someone on reddit
I'm sure is gonna try and put them all
together yeah we'll see what it means by
ah that's cool I like
Paris I want to see it teleport us out
yeah teleport us out there Paris breeze
there
I need a GTFO what happened oh no
something I'm about to die yeah like
that what sounds like a little miss oh
he's going on okay
oh man it's terrifying you know the
flashlight aspect dark spaces
yeah sure way to give me a freak out
oh my gosh I'm actually about to go to
check out some universal Halloween stuff
oh yeah ready to scream might as well
I get I get spooked so yeah you see I'm
a chicken you guys
so many of them get all amazed oh man
all and you get invincibility when
you're doing the finishing no I'm
standing in a little riff right now that
I manage I would just like these guys
does I want to get here took a couple
back scratches I think I'm just
whistling like they're just gonna keep
respawning until I uh fly back out ah
she noticed that I was like I had
electricity yeah cuz when they hit me
it's art damage and this is done
specifically charges up the more you get
hurt
[Music]
nightmares and [ __ ] it's scary but it's
very beautiful whoa whoa you know what I
realized to my super meter on the bottom
left
to guide the deeper vein of the
catacombs yeah it is October oh my god
oh my god the heebie jeebie you oh I
really don't like this area
I'm also want a lot of people that like
if you see a bunch of like little holes
your stuff together it kind of gives me
the choice like it just gives me like
the cringe billion might next like
constantly I'm like oh no for sure for
sure I feel that too oh that's a big boy
that's the big boy
yeah
[Music]
so those guys are exploding they will
blow up
oh wow he do feel
we've got this
whoo-hoo these are the plays right now
it's a PvE life man
and they'll race last event her costume
totally gave me destiny by yeah I should
have liked the whole helmet and
everything
visit
Bob jump says you're supposed to be
running away sorry Bob Jones is right
he's absolutely correct like destroy
them I know I know
well I also need to level up like xpy so
it's like I'm just getting ya know
vanishing this time bro we'll reload in
your face I just floated right out to
him like hey what's up hey you want to
give you a high-five
these the timing of him slamming down
was perfect after your line right you're
like oh what's up bro it's on your grave
and then he gets like I thought I was
pulling this head out alright
oh man it's in you all the way back yeah
yeah but it's alright we can all right
sweet nose out we're just gonna speed
run higher
this is that thing you do when you're in
strikes and you just skip Ricci press s
to listen to Bob we called it Bob he
knows what's up just sprint and then you
reap in the end of hand rewards oh my
god or will we get we are you've had
your moment Ari
I'm not giving them no highlights in
this
oh now I got hit with the smoke
not bad Oh mr. jump uh we're good we're
good
are you Morlocks have grazed of course
on away a lot of anything creepy shadow
oh you felt that that was the story
sorry I should just run up the stairs
actually that middle area of the said
[Music]
all right catacombs we're we're out of
here with the crypto glyph in hand we
stand a chance against the pyramid bring
it here and let us make you sit sounds
the plan nice all right we got some XP
bonus torch season ranked Oh got some
new lore - that's for me to read later
the privacy of my own so well this loads
it's a good time to check out the season
pass because this is new cool so this is
like your typical apex fortnight battle
pass in a sense right where they're
giving you because before it was like
this kind of washing down system where
you would just level up and if you maxed
out your current level and XP you would
just get this thing that's like Engram
you would send it to the ever verse
store which is like the micro
transaction here yeah and you had a
chance to get stuff and a lot of that
stuff was kind of dumb and I can be
honest only because it was RNG it was
random and you didn't know what you were
getting and at least with this you can
kind of see okay when I hit this level
I'm gonna be getting some more glimmer
I'm gonna get this artifact I'm gonna
get this Belgian flying
yeah I'm gonna get that you know what I
mean so you have an idea and there's
obviously there's a freebie track and
there's a the premium track and for
people who buy Shou to keep the premium
track is included for this season which
is gonna last another 68 days let me
have time plenty of time and if you
don't have it I think it's like 10 bucks
up to you guys but it's totally optional
all right you guys that armor will prove
useful in the battles to come but the
pyramid demands greater power to enter
it three further pieces of armor these
diseases torture the moon with their
very presence send them back to the past
where they belong and in return they
shall provide us with power does she
write poetry too I know you're spittin
bars
she's like my soundcloud like that it's
just it's just me ominously whispering
and you can be progressively more yeah
that's like so the Phantom eriana-3
haunts belong to rest right at burden
waves of mine cryptic leafless tree
using empowered the lectern of
Enchantment and tandem but the cleansed
essence of anguish as we hold another
piece of dream Bayon armor if this
didn't make any sense to you guys
I'm sorry in advance its it's really
simple basically you just have this item
that you need to cleanse and when you
cleanse this item you're using another
tool to help you cleanse that item in to
get armor and you need that armor to
kind of continue that that's that's the
TLDR basically they just like they're
really Amish and I love that but it's
dirty yeah there's no high darkness on
that that's what it is that's what you
need to know um so I just actually got
another season brewing so let's see what
we got for this one got a little emblem
I think
and some plumber give me that give me
that money I'm just gonna clip this and
to show off to people that I am on level
seven all right so this is the recognize
yeah you so the lectern of inch a man so
the cryptic lift that we just stole
we're gonna put it here there it is
that's not how did you figure out your
crypto clip so no I did so what happened
was the collection the collectors
edition came with a journal from Eris
over a letter a letter from arrows and a
map
but they're still but there were
journals for other stuff basically so
there was these hieroglyphs those hive
hieroglyphs that were on there and very
very very serously they were marked a
couple of them were mark there was like
twelve of them and four of them were
marked no one's like hey I recognize
those glyphs on this thing you know so
you just had to kind of change with the
order it's an angle with it a little bit
but in the end it opened up and it's
really cool I was very proud of it it's
off my desk right now
Oh 836 let's go
that's that's that life I'm talking
about where is it
dream bane boots yeah 836 Gaddy we rise
in your argument now everything else is
gonna get pulled up really quick in
comparison so we this is gonna be fun I
cannot wait eight ten okay fourteen
don't mind if I do
Oh eight fourteen here and that's the
legendary I will take that seventeen
this is a new exotic by the way premium
season pass owners get this right away
free track players will get at like
level 35 or something it's called
Ariana's Val it's a hand cannon with
like a sniper barrel attached to it and
the exotic perk for this is a fire
special shield piercing ammunition so
enemies that have shields you just pop
them once or twice it's like super
effective on it it's really really cool
I like that one a lot but it's a lower
level at the moment so we're just gonna
there's this two-tailed Fox rocket
launcher that yeah I think yeah yeah
it's cool it even has a t-shirt with it
and I gave it to my sister for a
birthday nay's this is how the rocket
originally looks which I kind of like
this look a little better yeah yeah it's
a really good look I love it a lot but
the ornament that I got for it was this
one and I think that's badass
heck yeah they're both great alright
seems like we got some nightmare
bounties which seems to be new and it
seems like they cost
phantasmal fragments well this one does
these ones are just going whoa whoa kid
did not expect it to react to me like
that what does this require
I met that destiny roadblock of farming
Matt's yep it was a portal gotta farm
gotta go in this portal I guess what
what just happened where that portal go
this is uncharted territory for me that
was snap we're discovering something
here first folks
maybe I'm sure a lot of people already
already this is exciting for me and
during a [ __ ] it matches your car
doesn't it spike I can't bring it out it
is unable to summon but look I won't go
isn't it cute yes like all sickly green
and goes I love it cuz that's the wrong
way yeah justice says to be honest you
don't even need forsaken you're you're
pretty much you're correct you don't
necessarily need it I think it's good to
have it if you want if you're a story
person because the campaign for forsaken
which was really good is locked behind
that and then there's also exotics there
are specific forsaken exotic weapons
that are locked with forsaken and the
rate the last wish rage over the past
these are great endgame content but like
I would play shadow keep first to be
honest just cuz that's when everyone
else is playing that's what your friends
are probably gonna play just jump in and
then you can do forsaken after no
there's no rush speak to I Cora that I
Cora is right here and this is a chest
the chest first attack to refresh I
gotta talk to you talking about you
better ask my permission
oh man
do-do-do-do-do you
I like I totally forgot loading screens
existed when I was playing on PC oh yeah
yeah yeah for sure
it's okay next-gen consoles are on the
way there we go
[Music]
I had to see it with my own eyes how
long has it sat in silence watching bass
much too long
I can't help but feel responsible for
this areas if I hadn't sent you here
your concern is noted that my feet is my
own responsibility and we both know you
didn't come here to apologize I came to
tell you you were right it seems those
responsible for our collapse are coming
back Oh
you're all inseparable save your torment
for someone who gives a damn
Eris the Vanguard is at your disposal
and if you'll excuse us I Cora we have
work to do
Guardian whatever she needs
I'm getting chills well that's that's
the same the level of
[Music]
kind of like the emotional story girl
[Music]
because you guys gonna say Eris used to
be a punch line in d1 she's like
genuinely she's dealing with some
genuine trauma that's nuts
yes and that pyramid is it something oh
man you missed it I had like a thank you
social crisis on this cutscene D that
was a loss for words that's insane
the nightmare cometh quest step alright
this is the time where you start like
usually check up on your quest you're
like oh did I finish any bounties what
can I turn in and all that fun stuff
probably by completing game a game at
prime crucible of exercise two strike
activity namwon said what happened to
destiny this actually looks interesting
new content man new content and new
content a reorg of their like design
philosophy and yeah it's beautiful but
that can happen to games now idea it's
like this has been out for a long time
now but it's still fresh and it's still
new because all this content absolutely
and also they split up Activision so
they're not right beholden to this
really strict deadlines of we need to
draw this much DLC we need to drop you
know a core content drop every like fall
or whatever you know what I mean like
like they delayed Shattuck your
Chowchilla specific amount of month ago
okay it looks great she was worth the
wait
exactly because it's so much in the past
they would have just released it and it
would have been half-baked and you would
have been like what what do we do right
and it's kind of like you always felt
like a better beta player when you were
playing destiny to be completely honest
you genuinely always felt like oh I'm a
guinea pig in this game it's not a fully
polished game but the way that they're
handling it now it feels a lot better
it's a little more respectful if you
like to veteran players too
just tuned in and ready to go I'm very
excited to see people in the office
talking about the game and having it be
in the discussion
kind of enjoying with the place yeah
that's always
this is a new section of the news area
we're going to who's that little big red
tower known as the Scarlet skeet
that was not in the moon in t1 in fact
the everything from here or rather this
section was og moon everything here and
I'm and I'm getting rekt food just
looking at the map they're not very
friendly to tourists
Britain's gonna run up in his house
anyways yeah don't a good not alone but
yeah this is cool and it looked like
there was a still a lot of open space on
that man by the way for sure okay shadow
kit requires the full three main armor
set which we do not have so what man so
we gotta get the armor and we defeat the
three remaining nightmare bosses to
collect the okay okay so I think we do
have to kill that guy make sense make
sense
probably just
thank you and I'm out of bullets
oh boy already going
ooh no skulls whoa
well we're not in the darkness section
so you can die like a dozen times over
and worry about it did they get all
their health back oh yeah but again it's
just like certain section right
yeah what is up with your load out here
the life of
hey all right this guy's helping us
thanks buddy okay oh look at him
just smack it from over there Tyrael see
this is an unstable essence it actually
gives you a little damage booth
I guess the nightmares which is nice
so pretty yeah they're really ornamental
a lot of the chests kind of reflect the
enemy types that surrounds it so the
hive ones are like kind of all thorny
and gross like the Cabal they look like
more like a military chess and falling
stuff looks like scavengers it's a
pretty cool supernova says is one or two
of that to contest I look at one with
Rose tinted glasses like all the time
but when you actually play one it's
absolutely just wipes the floor with
there because there's so many quality of
life improvements this whole directors
have the map that I keep going back to
you couldn't do that in destiny one if
you wanted to see him stab them if you
won't see map you had a back out of the
entire area wait
it's so ridiculous yeah it's just the
way that you join up with friends the
whole clan system everything's
I hope one day we do get to this level
in life where we could like go to the
moon and summon a vehicle I know it's
crazy it would be this is gonna be tough
I'm at 812 and we just spawned into a an
8:30 mission so we'll oh you get more XP
when you fight higher levels than you
yeah it only makes sense you know what
might actually have to happen we'll see
how this works but I could just do some
quick public events and stuff to get a
very quick power level because my boots
you'll see your 8:39 which is very high
but everything else is like really low
so but if they drop they're gonna be
dropping at least at the halfway mark
right around that 8 12 seconds
he to have succeeded
you see that red icon over them yes
that's the game telling you that these
enemies are going to be a little and if
they have a question mark over their
names oh yeah you see that she's had
shots and it's like not even yeah plus
oh boy all right look alive David can't
wait
ooh Dominic says David is good at
destiny but not so good a fantasy
football dang dong he came out swinging
oh man you know what's funny
dong had one good week but I'm in second
place in Thomson what's up Don thanks
for joining them like he exploded into a
bunch of like little blue crystals yeah
yeah off a heel to the forehead like man
all of these areas just brings me like
it's like flashbacks chris says
off-topic but last of us to is gonna be
epic to disks Wow yes that is
interesting to me because I feel like
what modern games came out that requires
cuteness like with Red Devils dead
students are
but it's like so I feel like it's more
rare announcer it is only once you
disagree think of a like Final Fantasy
like Final Fantasy 13 was like three
disks thanks
how big is that digital download 300
gigs I'm so curious what kickin in the
face shop completed okay I was just told
me it's time for you and finishes on the
don't look at it
I'll just check them out
yeah we'll go with that yeah I was
getting ready he's like he's like wait
wait I gotta get I gotta get ready for
this one
you're on fire but not in the good way
yeah I'm the good fight
this guy he was like yeah he's running
now yeah
finish her into menu the combos hmm
you're dying you're dying his risk
runner is very good yes these guys we're
gonna do a quick click little infuse way
up to
it'll be better for
yeah but if I can
you're good height advantage so supers
are regenerating way slower than they
used to after the patch and I think they
did that so it encourages you to tweak
things ooh got some lore oh snap
because my radars going off but I think
they're on the ground which is why it's
freaking out because if I remember this
correctly this is gonna loop around and
go under there yeah yeah d1 veteran
status I remember this place your own
business and you walk in they look so up
and I'm like sup boys easy so I'm gonna
swap to the defensive super just in case
I have a feeling we're gonna hit a boss
I said if it's not the golden age drop
cake did you really finish that's a good
point though I think we can get go with
the let's go cool nice job thank you
there we go that draw fake is brutal man
that's like a as a disrespectful word
right there
circle of bones I am
yeah
you say you're a wizard yeah the running
sorry he's like a whiner
oh no dude he's really gone see that
forum oh you know I give him an A for
effort the strat waited to looks away
I've not seen in a - astrology the way
for you to get the chance ever so
slightly outward - to get you to like
see he was there yeah man that was top
selling hey bro
oh that boy okay oh the guy you said you
hope didn't we don't want to do kameez
don't use grenades Davi well now with
the war locker days I mean they're good
for hands I just like you never gave you
said shoot I like the I mean I'm a
hunter main and I had a swap to a
warlock for the purposes of coverage
because bill our reviewer is already
John Luke he's a hunter as well and I
was hey guys take him to a team
literally home okay I do like that one
better
yeah I mean I was the Warlock main on
destiny 1 and then when it came out up
from CEOs like
oh boy
oh that really know just like later out
this making you pay for those horrible
reload when you're when you're not in
the darkness zone it's like you're so
careless it's like okay I'm just gonna
respond anyway look this guy he thinks
I'm okay darkness um this is sorry well
you have to care a little more so
they're a little more you kind of you a
lot you know stuff out of the way hope
to get some some gear maybe I know we're
still under level we are still
technically under level although I think
okay well we've got the skills above
levels so it evens out I think we're
gonna be okay this chest piece is really
bringing me down
but I like ya jumping up a little bit
see what else is now that's it okay cool
we're 15 under level this is gonna be
great
I think if if there's a big chain doger
I feel like oh it's gonna come out of
that big red or it's a surprise open I
didn't see what's good this is this was
like a strike in testing one and my god
but it used to be changed
these walls here oh good I'm tamanna he
wants me to go to the nightmare you
kidding even think about like yeah yeah
I told you I told you I was like come on
man yeah I believe yeah it's already
yeah you see that whole bar on the
bottom it didn't move you just sneeze
the moderator
oh man and then there's gonna be ads
like left and right oh man oh man
we even have enough ammo Vitter's buy it
I just unloaded force times right
oh man let me go back to my man do and
fine gear that I know I don't have let's
get boxes aim for the stomach this is
you to the stomach stomach was a clear
spot but I think so is his head in this
version of the nightmare the stomach had
a
oh yeah just like
they're running now
relax
David
trying to stop there
it's gonna be a stress it's the night
most rad
yeah yeah right in the belly that's if
you get leave in your belly out
maybe a way for the
Piper today you got to give a blow by
blow account all right so I'm gonna
update it taking cover behind the pillar
but the chain over is getting wild he's
sitting out his and now the whole squad
is suffocating David behind this pillar
this is the least of his worries oh
that's dumb you're like I should've died
you got this I believe you
we're just gonna get down here spoke up
can't get me here oh no he oh he could
take me there was not expecting him to
have that level of uh yeah Emmett I
think this is a destiny one it's uh yeah
well the moon is a destiny one map so
there's gonna be a lot of areas over but
this specific spot and this specific
nightmare boss is wasn't destined to
strike
holy moly you at least get like the XP
from doing parts of this without it like
when I'm finishing it up course that's
good I mean it's not going to be as not
says beating him
and David using the environment for
protection but he needs to back away
oh my god robbers
I'll see you that's what we took it down
last time give in the same spot there oh
no no we're not good we're not gonna be
okay
ain't scott.woods now we're good right
in the belly
give him indigestion
create yeah
it's like 55
keep hitting me really
speed in those bullets
is it
like being back it's all good it's all
good this this one's gonna be it because
the guy can do it I'm gonna have my
super this time so I can do it for the
second round good
we got this and to think all this could
have been avoided by just if like one or
two public toilets now this is what we
live for
it's you know reminiscent of life can
get anywhere about going through the
difficult things first all right whoo
think the word for this really amazing
infinite flip we have here you know what
you have some sort of perk on did it was
history
okay alright so I'm gonna do I'm gonna
grab that
yeah
take a breather
it's like when you run out of stamina in
the game yeah it's like
we're out of that we got
since you get a phase where I can pop
no not this time nights
although it's pretty much too old
nitrate
until you beat this dance
do that essence going back
I know right posture phogoth yeah
Wow
thank goodness this pillar is
indestructible
[Music]
all the real focus please stand up for
real not this nightmare version
this is gonna be days where
[Music]
they're not showing up
there's nothing they could do about you
as well yeah
I was
okay that like third-person moment
freaked me out
cuz I just fall to be more take them out
now
Oh
David you're so close
don't let this back up you don't want
this compact up he's taking us out again
Nate can't explain
my back oh my god
yep it's your best
use this time to scratch your back David
- boy I got you wild you were so wild 3
you think I saw one a little bit -
laughs yeah
all right
oh I'm right you just kind of finished
with jobs right now
we know
oh no I hear people here people come on
it's like another way that just spotters
like we got it dude guys we got this
stuff man oh boy
that's fun I'll see what better reward
you heavily they better man don't
ridiculous yeah give me that give me the
armor I probably should have had a head
going into uh going into that nice sick
sick sick sick sick oh that's the moon
that's the moon you should definitely be
able to see my ship but for some reason
it's not loading in so we get this nice
aerial view of the moon this is actually
hidden footage SMA geo said what gun is
that so I'm assuming the gun that you're
probably talking about was that the
lightning infinite clip one and that one
is a risk runner it's a destiny one
exotic that I have used a lot and I love
and I still use to this day and it's
really really really really cool those
perks on it are absolutely ridiculous
and I have a little catalyst that
freakin maxes out that range really good
being rich II don't get me hype you said
Taco Tuesday and I like got a little
spark of hope and I was like wait it's
not Susie mm-hmm it's definitely
Wednesday Bob wait okay really
Bob Jones is also correct if you hold
the left sugar you can just see kind of
like what your values are at right now
and what element they are which is
helpful to get a chest piece yeah
yeah do we you're still getting weighed
down yeah you still are well we got we
got these things we got the more
essences right so divide three remember
to collect their essences essence of
fear isolation and pride so we have fear
and greed I don't know if greed is even
yeah greed rewards you a nice specific
weapon the fear is one of them
so we got to kill hive on the moon so
let's freaking go I'm ready to slaughter
some hive oh yeah it's team lunch day I
guess so let's use a different subclass
we can get some fun things in there and
let's go and kill some hi for the next
like 20-something minutes - one two -
there you go
hi I'm trying member how did you on
console I want to do the flips use RT
while airborne okay pigs up we're gonna
go off and probably die but look at that
straight I feel like you could have
landed that maybe but I was just like I
was on the I was off the bat so that way
oh yeah any any jump that I can do we
can now do flips and stuff so I'll be
the moon has specific like launch pads
are like little ramp so you kind of go
off and do your own thing these are all
falling these are not for people who
want to kill thing to the coffin mess to
she say yeah keep Brandon yes you
perfected
now you're gonna land on them for extra
style plants like really try running
over
I just hit him a little bit gave him a
little nudge no you went invisible he's
actually stuck to running your car I've
ever seen grease uh yeah no I just know
the song in the end he like races his
rivals but his car has like will spike
something else I was like originally got
that concept from Greece just kidding
right
always secretly loved stumbling
animations yeah so funny
I cannot wait for like two weeks down
the road one like the nightmare hunts
and all the season and seasonal pass
content starts coming out yeah there's
still more on the way that's crazy so
much and if we start streaming that
stuff like later down the road if
there's nothing you know no big releases
or anything then you guys are gonna be
some crazy guns by that there's bull
John Luke myself all the rage sound so
fun how's the season three on apex I
also have to say you probably could just
dream that see all day I know apex life
although I've been playing this holiday
team oval and today he goes oh yeah I
don't like low-key addicted to it
already yet that that's when he kills
sweet right yeah
twenty killed Doug Diane
yeah I mean you know everyone's playing
on mobile so everyone's bad so it's like
I just have like the ever so slight
advantage right that gamers yeah like
say my first radio
Oh
excuse me miss that pillar-like blocked
it looks yeah it was like now that's too
violent it's like you can't see that one
Hey yeah a peg has been pretty fun
then that the map is cool massive bone
yeah I do enjoy landing on the train I
don't know why I just see the train a
lot I've never actually liked this is
true Bob Jones they do love me some
Tetris this is this chair that touches
life touches my knee Diane is so awesome
you want to see a one-hand kamehameha
yes that's basically offices
peckerhead it directed
that was Beverly Maire olds from
overwatch although who came first
recommended power 870
Waverly that's that's interesting though
there are enemies that cuz that's oh
he's got a skull you see that what is
that uh Nicole he just healed that's
what that thing was on his back features
it was a healing shield oh my god good
yeah alright buddy you are you got it
there's no way I'm getting that one
thank God for fast travel Jesus we got
15 minutes you know we can do we can do
this strike that's a good way to to send
it off cool
oh man yeah you the the 30 FPS on xbox
hey you know that kind of sucks at least
I have 4k now and Xbox 1x is really good
with handling that as is the ps4 pro but
if you have a PC and you have like a 10
60 at least just go a PC it's it's so
much nicer plus if you really like the
controller you can play with the - oh
yeah you know what I mean and the aim
assist and everything kind of kicks in
and it's like super super super fun I
enjoy it quite a bit
I mean try and see if I can use that
exotic and we'll save that sniper for
later and just stick with this
I'm gonna go double hand cannon day
let's go all right what which one of
these icons look cooler
the Warlock doing this or the Warlock
doing doing this definitely am bowing
about to throw the Hadouken all right so
we're gonna run this this Nova more Nova
warp brother and it's kind of its kind
of anime is she like Popeye you can like
warp around and do some really cool
things what's up Fred oh he needs your
help David he says I've had this game on
launch on Xbox but haven't played it in
about two years I'm getting it again but
want to know what's the best class
ticket that's a hard one man I would say
let's put it like this yeah what's your
play style what's your play style yeah
if you or hey you got some somebody's
here let's go um yeah what what is your
play style that's definitely I know what
you want to to focus on if you feel like
a lone ranger solo player you like to
play bass at the post fight
and you don't mind having a slow health
recovery go hunter if you are a person
who still likes to do a lot of damage
output maybe aren't as maybe not as
sturdy like your health isn't that
strong but you're okay like you're able
to weave in and out and really yeah but
kind of like you saw how I was doing
earlier where I was hiding behind regen
going back and using like sort of these
abilities more to play your play style
and you go warlock but if you are just
an OG like the Master Chief halo Spartan
type person you got to go Titan and
those kind of like are the three main
things but the best thing that you want
to do is you want to have people who
have the other sub classes as well
because those guys are going to be able
to kind of play to your strengths right
or they can tell with some goofy kisses
it's kind of like
[Music]
yeah teamwork exactly Timur thanks
oh I'm a goofy he said we wanted to the
purpose of us Here I am there yeah
so the Scarlet keeps a new strike it's
also a strike that's available to
everyone even people who don't own
shadow key so that's that's pretty good
he said a Fredo says his silos damaging
and fast-paced attacker
so what sir he was more of like a
damaging slash fast-paced attacker
damaging slash fast-paced attacker okay
well then I think a hunter or a
tightener is probably gonna do
[Music]
so those guys are gonna go to that tower
is this really a bagel nice he's really
a bagels he's gonna go to that tower we
will go to this stop yeah and I'm about
to jump off no I'm not I don't know if
I'm Melissa oh my goodness even you
can't let the team down the dream can't
work if if you die
[Music]
Carol arrow says have you finished a
story no so we were halfway through the
story about 2/3 of the way on the last
bus but once you finish the story you
get a exotic place
music
I've got the ball go in for the
touchdown
pretty much ma'am she's Louise holding
is like two great touchdown where they
right now be closing like shoulder check
them with them or stiff arm them on your
land on the regular football field that
definitely would have been much more
impact I just like traveled though she
took like eight stabs Oh
so your boy tonight
oh no that ogre I like where
trying to go for the airhead shot and
now
is that all
decaf Raman says have the load times on
console been improved um I can't say for
sure because I don't play console often
there are low times obviously but I
think what I use the year about load
times is sending in the like two minutes
like those wool yeah we finished our
request that the one that was like $100
so now I got to visit that like you that
I Darryl last is this game good guy you
know it's not good it reads all right
you can like war that's awesome is this
your other ultimate the other one you
had was the one with the sword right so
right right and they have two forms so
this one was like this like you know
purple super same thing yeah other
version of it did you just like throw
like a one-hit bomb that floats towards
my clothes it's interesting the sword
one has two variations series all right
one was when I was in the air chucking
the swords the other one was when I
planted it into the ground and pretty
cool the art one was the common hot but
the other ones like this Palpatine you
like to float around and there's some
fun stuff hunters and Titans have their
own supers as well it's a good time
Oh interesting Emma said attach an SSD
on your xbox one X and you'll get a much
quicker loading fund that could be true
I do have that I have an SSD that I plug
into my xbox just to like install more
games and it makes sense yeah most of
the things are tied to have Michos
memory in general
to sniper this
so crazy like the range on the stages
its shadow Keith and season pass the
only things you have to buy to get all
the content this year depends what you
have already right if you are a brand
cooler you're a brand new player sorry
I'm like floating into this guy you know
just like no photographer yeah okay if
you hear a brand new player you have to
get a little more than just shadow key
because there's the forsaking stuff
that's like they're trying to frame that
as optional now if you already own
everything yeah
oh the deluxe oh it's included with
shadow okay
the deluxe edition includes all forces
and stuff so you're separating tired
oh yeah yeah you see you growing yeah
like then we have three people yeah one
of the problem do you feel it mr. Krabs
checkinside you can eat your grenade and
go in the dusk
it's a one-hit kill and it's like super
close range but I love that she is eager
to return that ping yeah Kota was a
great boss destiny one as was Oryx
they're all basically one big not so
happy family serious go to bed it was
the son of Oryx you killed Kota and it
pisses or ticks off
there's an entire expansion based around
or it's just like being super livid and
destroying everything and they're
they're crazy bosses man these guys work
huge but now I guess crotas daughter is
kind of pissed and this holdup in this
section that's beautiful art
final box and bagel means business
that's ignore all dessert
oh yeah came out yep
my back and head
check out this intimidating reload dude
I'm a fan of this exotic the the slow
reload kind of sucks but like it packs a
punch man yeah for sure
it's like 18,000 of that
he's got four minutes to take down crota
Oh
oh dang this feels like a carnival game
yes like hit all the targets
Oh as soon as I said that I was like
it's bacon and I was like wait where
your bagel go now where did big we go
oh no we're bagel as' it's all you now
big Oh God oh boy
seven in the chat so David really out
here killing it in death
my life is like oh snap a new chest
armor Oh Biggles that oh nice thanks
bagel
all right you gotta get a second ago
with this business she certainly can be
quite soothing yes well
so rude trying to enjoy the landscape
nice
is my pc always being better the way
that Bungie makes shooting field on a
console is unparalleled man it feels so
good they know what they're doing I
really do
[Music]
stop hiding behind your minions crotas
so yeah Oh daughter daughter Kota yeah
she's got a weird name it's like
[Music]
good anyone it's severely under level
that's at 750 and I'm just
it's gonna be an easy boss
easy I'm gonna protruding together
we're breathing together whoa that was
weird
I'll try to do a selfie because we're
going oh yeah
we'll do slope yeah oh look at it Oh
chilly that's so cool actually dad the
emotes in this game
I saw like Call of Duty try to do these
notes and black ops for and they came
out and I was like look at man alright
let's go boss I know gate
here she comes
quick work
you guys
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
like I was just pieces everywhere how 54
is out
here
look your homeboy again
the music so evidence
ah
[Music]
say goodbye
[Music]
it's over relief to hear but hash
legends presence is no coincidence
you're so bad at this bagel official
legged oh it's enjoying his cocktail you
know oh yeah yeah yeah I got the picture
alright y'all sit in it right on time
GG's destinies huge shadow keep its out
its available hop on that you guys and
yeah thanks David
sir everybody else GameSpot live every
weekday 11:00 a.m. Pacific time right
here on youtube.com slash GameSpot and
on our website as well so weird
so much stuff up there man we've got GFS
graphics comparisons coming up man we
got all this stuff going GameSpot check
it out have a good time yeah and so next
time we will see you later peace out